security officials are starting to close
off and blockade streets around the u.s
capitol in anticipation of a trucker
convoy that could make its way to
washington fox news has learned that
fencing will go up around the capitol
perimeter ahead of president biden's
state of the union speech march first at
the same time a top democratic pollster
tells axios the party needs to start
attacking the so-called maga faction
quote that's a much better foil than
just talking about picking one obscure
congressional leader that nobody will
know anyway or a feature presidential
nominee that nobody will know anyway
trump is not on the ballot but these
maga faction candidates are
kaylee mcinerney your thoughts yeah i
think you just laid out some very
important context here as we're hearing
that there could be a freedom convoy in
the united states with truckers you lay
out the axios piece emily which says
president biden must have a foil um in
other words the guy in the basement
needs a bad guy
no one voted for president biden because
they thought he had mental acuity they
thought he had grand plans and a vision
for the nation we didn't really even
know his plan because he was in the
basement most of the time people voted
on basement boy because they just
decided they didn't like mean tweets so
this is very important context to say
you know in 2016 he had trump as a foil
right now he doesn't have that and i
really hope he does not try to make
these u.s truckers uh the bad guy
because that will be disastrous i don't
want to see our country go the way of
ottawa where i follow the ottawa police
who who say you know hey there's going
to be financial repercussions for these
protesters we're going to find you
you're at an unlawful protest and just
merely your presence you could be
arrested i really hope we don't get to
that place in the united states
that's right it's a terrifying thought
and brian part of the argument as well
is that by making by creating that
maggot candidate foil it's essentially
taking the focus up and out from the
inward foil that the democratic party is
currently facing which is as kaley
points out an incompetent president that
has failed on every level and there's so
much civil war going on within the
democratic party as they argue over what
should be the priorities to this party
for this country for its american
citizens that they're trying to shift
the blame elsewhere brian yeah they
don't need to invent a foil reality is
giving them all sorts of foils it's
called inflation it's called education
policy it's called the border there's
all sorts of problems for them to solve
the problem for the democrats is they're
looking to spin
somebody to blame instead of dealing
with the wreckage they've created on
these policies you look at the freedom
convoy
president biden all he sees there is an
opportunity to create another enemy to
create another foil instead of listening
listen to these guys they are the
backbone of moving goods around this
country that is a problem america needs
solve maybe we should listen to their
concerns maybe the president should get
ahead and act a little bit on them and
just maybe if he did that we'd start to
address some supply chain issues we'd
start to address some inflation issues
he wouldn't have to create foils because
he'd actually have some good news for
once in his administration
and leslie part of the sort of
frightening developments that are
happening in canada that as kaley was
talking about we would we would uh
hopefully never see here in the united
states but it's maybe starting to be
married and that's the financial
de-platforming so david sachs argues
financial d platforming has arrived with
the use of emergency powers there in
canada saying last summer he said i
warned readers of common sense that
financial d platforming would be the
next wave of online censorship big tech
companies like paypal were already
working with left group left-wing groups
he argues like the adl and splc to
define lists of individuals and groups
who should be denied service these
deplorables would be de-platformed
de-banked and eventually denied access
to the modern economy altogether as
punishment for their unacceptable views
that prediction has become reality and
here leslie as you know the supreme
court has ruled that your political
fundraising your political donor
how you choose to spend your money
politically is a form of free speech but
there we are seeing that worse
prediction that worst nightmare coming
true could it happen here
i don't think so because you just
mentioned free speech that doesn't cross
the border by the way canada doesn't
have the first amendment that we do
which is one of the reasons america is a
great country that it is uh but when it
comes to these private companies first
amendment doesn't extend to them they're
allowed to do blocking and if that
includes financial blocking they are
allowed that i don't think it's all doom
and gloom and i want to say very quickly
on to the point of a foil because i am a
democrat i don't think we need a foil
voters care about time and time again
poll after poll after poll c c c cash
covered crime that's what they care
about and don't don't faint i always
tell democrats take a page out of the
republican gop playbook and that is
there there are tons of republicans
nearly half or more of the party that
really didn't like donald trump but when
he was the candidate that party united
and got behind them and worked together
and there's too much uh fragmentation in
my party right now and they should unite
more and they should focus on the issues
and not donald trump or anybody else to
come up as the bad guy and and history
has shown me in recent history a
gubernatorial race in virginia is one
example of that uh you know terry
mcauliffe just you know harped on trump
and he lost
right i wish your party would listen to
you more and voters like you leslie
although maybe not because it's going to
be such a red one not important enough
guys
hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want
you to do me a favor i want you to click
to subscribe to the fox news youtube
page this is the only way that i know
for sure that you're not going to miss
any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on fox you can get it all here on
youtube so subscribe right now